the award for best sound is a young
woman who's made some beautiful sounds
herself tonight ladies and gentlemen
once again Irene Cara six-track Dolby
stereo there's thx but do you know
what's the best sound of all hearing
your name after and the winner is one of
these groups of nominees is about to
realize that the nominees for
achievement and sound are bill Barney B
Tennyson Sebastian the second Robert
Thoreau L and William B Kaplan fir back
to the future Dada Mitchell Michael
McClure Terry Humphreys and Chris Newman
for a chorus line let's brush folks dick
Alexander Verne poor and bud Alper for
Ladyhawke Chris Jenkins Gary Alexander
Larry Stan's volt and Peter Hanford for
out of Africa
Donald Oh Mitchell Rick Klein Kevin
O'Connell and David Ronnie for Silverado
and the winner and the winners are Chris
Jenkins Gary Alexander
at Universal and a special debt of
gratitude to Sydney [ __ ] for putting
his trust in us when there's so many
other talented people around he shares
his enthusiasm for sound and his special
gift work with us and I can't say enough
about what he donated to this so thank
you very much
I'd like to thank John Berry Danny loan
and clip Kolok for such great music to
work with I'd like to thank the Academy
for such a wonderful honor thank you
like to thank everyone and Tommy
McCarthy jr. and just thanks miss tang
to the Academy for this wonderful honor
and also Sydney [ __ ] for his patience
and waiting with all those aircraft to
stop and go away from the center and for
those marvelous actors who just said
their words I just sort of sit back and
listen it's a pleasure thank you very
much